they will face zach wheeler making his
third start against the atlanta braves
this year
he comes in overall four and three at
2.51 era wheeler's ready to go and
here's the o2 pitch to all these again
he went around in fact he dropped the
bat he may have hurt his hands
first strikeout of the day for zach
wheeler and it culminates a one two
three first inning
facing ian anderson making his 12th
start got a break the ball in the dirt
swung and missed but herrera is able to
steal second because that was a good
change
walk stolen base ground out has a double
herrera 90 feet away the pitch is sky
toward right center
not very well hit and ender is there and
that retires the side so anderson threw
a lot of pitches but put up a zero and
the braves go to work in the second
scoreless
right side can segura get there he does
gets to his feet throws to first what
they play
he has played some gold glove second
base on this home stand alone without a
doubt
one thing to get to it but to get to his
feet as quickly as he did remarkable
[Music]
got a long way to go this is a great
shot
that shows you how far he had to go
does this push up while sliding head
first gets to his feet you know what
kind of arm he has
one pitch to him
ground ball left side
safe
yeah
way to hustle
all right so
where does this happen where did you get
the speed from
who's he getting the speed from
well that's a good question
probably janine she's a she's a runner
no balls in a strike for ronald teres
and he golfs this one toward
shallow right field acuna is there and
anderson had a much easier inning he
gave up the infield hit and that is all
we head to the third no score
swinging abyss he went upstairs that's
the third strikeout for wheeler
what out kevin smith is coming up
oh two count
a check swing and a
slow roller up the middle for the first
graves hit of the game
off the hands popped up out towards
short
terreyes is there and he makes the catch
acunu jr was about three feet from home
plate
as that ball was grabbed
no runs one hit and one man left will go
to the bottom of the third and the 2-2
pitch to sigour
broken back that's a fair ball balcony
jr was playing that way so this is only
going to be a single though it's bobbled
by punya
so a two-out single it gives bryce
harper a chance to bat here in the third
knuckled out toward
austin riley into the shift and his
throw to first is in bloody attack well
that ball came off the bat funny
harper's retired so are the phillies no
score after three
there's a shot over the shortstop's head
for a base hit dansby swanson's on base
streak continues with atlanta's second
hit
one ball and two strikes down monte
and the pitch
swinging the miss he got
98 miles an hour on that four seat
fastball seven strikeouts
swing and a miss tipped and caught
actually and anderson has his second
strikeout
like the fact time that he's not getting
us solely with the punch-out
that one's pulled down the left-field
line that's going to be in for a base
hit and it's going to trickle to the
warning track
and tires is going to get himself to
second base
that ball is golf towards second but
ozia short hop makes the play
and ian anderson with a couple of
strikeouts and a ground up sends us to
the sixth
swing of the miss and that's eight
strikeouts
of course number one
breaking ball strike three call that's
nine strikeouts for wheeler
10 strikeouts again for zach wheeler he
strikes out the side
it's the fifth time this year he's
reached double digits and strikeouts
13th in his career
2-2 swung on and missed got him with a
good two-seamer that was sinking
struck him out
four strikeouts for ian
check swing that's going to trickle
right in front of the plate and anderson
gets a breeze through the sixth inning a
gift from reese hoskins and our duel
continues freddie freeman leads off the
score of seven
freeman shoots one
to the left side of the second base bag
that's a little more like it for freddie
freeman
his second hit of the series and for the
second time in three frames tom the
braves have the lead off man on
swing at a foul tip that time andrew nat
hung on 11 strikeouts
top of the eighth inning it's a
scoreless ball game the braves and the
phillies
as zach wheeler will go to work swag and
a mess he got him
how about a dozen strikeouts today for
zach wheeler he has reached double
digits and strikeouts
in four of his last five starts
pretty
incredible
that once it out toward right field
acuna junior's going back it is up the
top of the wall oh doable heading to
second base it's bottled by acuna and
odooba will stop at second
son of a gun
didn't get it out of the box as quickly
as he wanted
he's got a run
because this ball is bobbled by a cuny
and
i think he could have made the third
easily now segura who is one for three
but our leads off second
[Applause]
over to third base past riley down the
left-field line herrera is around third
heading for home he's gonna score the
phillies are on top one to nothing
about it
freddy is 1-4-3 today
swing and a fly ball hammer to center
herrera back at the 401 leaping try
can't get it
freddie freeman has homer to center
field and the braves are off the deck
they've tied the game
that was shades of herrera in the bushes
a couple of years ago
he had a beat on it and missed it two
balls no strikes
spiked another one that got away
streaking to the plate
is
dansby swanson and the braves take the
lead
seven straight balls from alvarado and
the braves catch a break to take the
lead
ready as smith and acuna the braves base
runners
and that got away
streaking to the plate and scoring is
heredia atlanta leads 3-1 two wild
pitches and a cloud of dust
is the extra rudder
and alec balm is the hitter office away
base hit for ball to run score
it's now three to two and that means the
time run is at first
[Music]
that pass ball by marchand
so pivotal here
shot the other way that's a fair ball
going down the left field live balm on
his way to third going to second bases
oh double
that means the tying run is at third the
winning run is at second
back to back doubles for o'double
herrera
it's second and third with nobody out
if there's a base hit to left this
game's over
as the runners lead off
the pitch coming to segora
now to left center field well hit
almonte is going back toward the 387
sign it's off the top of the wall
ball will score here comes
oh dugo herrera round third he'll score
gene
he's bringing everybody out to where the
ball was
the phillies win it four to three here
at the bottom of the 10th knitting
the celebration around gene sedora
walk me off two times
back-to-back walk-offs for the fells
they win the series
man he
rushed his